[Music]
[Applause]
Scott Fowler he was representing the
Charlotte Observer and he had some
questions to ask to David teer or at
least Tred to and he joins us on the
program Scott let me go back to when
Frank Reich was fired what was your
reaction to
that well I guess it had been coming a
little bit Dan uh only because I've been
here since the Inception of the p and
have watched David teer work he is not
patient he fired Matt rule Med season
last year and so when Frank Reich
started one and 10 it did feel a little
like demle sore dangling there I sort of
thought he would get till the end of the
year uh he only got 11 games in a in a
four-year deal and when I spoke with him
yesterday I think the only interview
he's done so far he did sound somewhat
surprised but he also said he had no
hard feelings toward Tupper what was the
atmosphere at the press conference
today very tense uh you mentioned that I
tried to ask some questions and I did I
sat in the front row raised my hand High
Unfortunately they were calling on
people as opposed to allowing people to
shout out their questions which I'm
usually decent at doing but uh was never
called on I think that was purposeful uh
for in my opinion I'd written written
some very critical columns about Dave
teer over the past year or so and so uh
that did not happen he spoke about 13
minutes though and what did happen was
he said uh the buck stops here uh he
claimed he was a very patient man
however and so that's a clip you
probably would like to play at some
point but yeah he said he was extremely
patient in other parts of his business
and he hoped the next guy he hired would
be here 20 or 30 years and would
eventually give the eulogy at Dave teer
funeral so he was thinking very far
ahead there and uh you know he struck
out a couple of times here but he's got
hope that he'll get it right this time
does he realize he's the
problem no I don't think so I think uh
you know as I wrote I wish he would fire
himself and by that I don't mean sell
the team I mean just get out of the way
you know don't don't medal and allow the
football people to do their job and once
you hire them allow them some time you
know if you say Rome's not going to be
built in a day don't expect the Coliseum
to be halfway done after three months I
mean they they've got a lot of work to
do here and now they just took a couple
of steps backward and the thing that
kept coming up to me and trying to find
out did Frank Reich really want rice
young or did he want CJ strad and the
role that the owner the the owner always
does this well owners can do this where
they Bigfoot people who do their job the
entire year getting ready for the draft
then all of a sudden the owner is going
to be adamant and say no no this is the
guy I want Jerry Jones famously has done
this and other owners but what role do
you think that David teer played in
drafting Bryce
young in that case although there's a
you know kind of a myth out there that
David teer overruled everyone and and
picked young over CJ strout I'm not sure
it's that simple uh he did address that
in the press conference today teer did
and he did say that Bryce young was the
preference of of every key coach and GM
and Scout in that room and he could have
vetoed but he did not he also thought
Bry young was better now is that exactly
the way it went down I don't know but
Frank Reich has never told me in all our
conversations that oh no I wanted CJ
strad even though CJ Stroud's kind of a
Frank W quarterback in terms of poise
and height and all that he seemed very
sold on Bryce young and uh remains so
even now after you know Bryce Young's
lack of development really I think cost
him his job more than anything else how
desirable is this head coaching
position well Dan put it this way
they're paying the last two guys they
fired Frank Reich has a nice consolation
prize of you know of a four-year
guaranteed contract he coached nine
months so he's got you know I don't know
what it is 25 30 million coming his way
if he doesn't get another job Matt rule
of course they're still paying some
money too he went to Nebraska but
there's some money at stake there so in
that way financially still very
desirable as far as winning though I
mean my gosh if you count interim
coaches which I do because that's a
little more fun uh the in January they
will hire their seventh coach since teer
took over in 2018 forehead guys three
interims well he inherited Ron Rivera
who you could argue he may have stuck he
should have stuck with maybe the entire
time but in any case this will be it's
been a lot it's been about once a year
Dan that we've been doing this sort of
thing are they the second coming of
Washington well I'll say this for Dave
terer he doesn't have Dan Snider's U you
know off
uh baggage yeah exactly no I I mean I I
will give terer credit for um you know
he's changed the stadium around the
Dynamics of Charlotte there's all kind
of concerts and there a lot of he's
great in charity it hasn't been the off
the field baggage but in terms of
results and the spinning Carousel of
coaches Etc uh it feels a little like
that but okay he goes he's a he grew up
a Steeler fan correct right and and had
was a minority owner there okay why
wouldn't you model your franchise after
the Steelers
patience get the right guy they've had
what three coaches in the last 50 years
right yeah Tomlin still never having had
he's still looking for his Mike Tomlin I
mean he keeps uh you know he references
the Steelers sometimes but it it sort of
is a hollow reference at these times
because you've just you've seen this
over and over he own also owns the major
league soccer team here Dan and has
fired two coaches and two there
but he is a patient man patient man I'd
hate to see if he wasn't patient
Scott uh I hope you get to ask what was
your question that you were gonna ask
him uh it was I was just he was talking
a lot about self-reflection so I was
going to ask him let's self-reflect just
for a minute you know you fired the last
three coaches you've had you fired them
all in midseason and I just wonder if
you ever look in a mirror and think is
it me am I the problem I think he did a
really wise thing of not calling on you
Scott maybe so you might be right keep
fighting the good fight there Scott
thanks for joining us thanks always a
pleasure d That's Scott fer been with
the Charlotte Observer since uh 1994